c'est une façon de dire merci à la ville
sébastien onomo et producteur et
scénariste
vendredi 28 octobre clayes-sous-bois il
présentait aux spectateurs le gang des
antilles et j'ai commencé ici aux
clayes-sous-bois un tourner des courts
métrages et une soutien de la ville sur
sur différents projets et comment j'en
suis arrivée à faire de la production
par une par une vie rennes fra simple
inquiets on n'est jamais mieux servi que
par soi même assez rapidement en fait on
a été convaincu par le potentiel du film
pour plusieurs raisons parce que d'abord
c'est un film qui parlait d'un aspect
méconnu de l'histoire française qui est
le b 'mid homme s'était fait une bonne
dizaine de bureaux de poste je me
sentais comme un smicard dur de plus
besoin demandez je voulais plus du petit
doigt l'état je vous laisse un mode tout
entière braquage de bureaux de poste
racisme et pantalons pattes d'éléphant
c'est une plongée dans la france
métropolitaine des années 1970 en plein
boom et d'homme quand de nombreux autres
marins arrive en métropole
alliée dans la métropole les habitants
de la martinique de la guadeloupe et de
la veille
le gang des antilles et raconte
l'histoire de jimmy la rivière inspiré
du récit autobiographique de l'eau et
qu'il est riche en prison ce film
témoigne d'une véracité historique ça
c'est sûr mais ce fut aussi une portée
beaucoup plus plus diverses parce que
récit que ce l'histoire n'aurait
concerné évidemment que ceux qui
s'intéressent mais on avait en tout cas
envie c'est bastia et dont les fines ici
et moi de faire un vrai film un vrai
film qui avait une portée au delà de
l'histoire au delà des personnages
quelque chose qui peuvent être un outil
afin peut-être pédagogique mais aussi un
outil de cinéma le film a reçu le et blu
d'or du festival de la page à l'image du
croisic
les aventures du gang des antilles et
sont à découvrir à partir du 30 novembre
prochain